the grandparents of a boy in a
high-profile international custody
battle are under arrest for their
alleged role in his abduction we first
told you about Nicholas Braun's story
more than two years ago in 2013 the boy
was taken to Brazil by his mother
Marcel Gere Maryse he's been there ever
since Nico's father wants the boy back
Michelle Miller who spoke with the dad
is in Los Angeles Michelle good morning
good morning Christopher bran had turned
to the FBI two years ago for help but
hadn't heard about this case until
yesterday
now with federal authorities involved
he's hoping that the arrest of Nico's
grandparents means his son is one step
closer to coming home he's an amazing
little boy I think you'd enjoy getting
to know him Christopher bran saw his son
Nicholas in Brazil just last week the
Houston physician found out about the
arrests in a surprise Wednesday morning
call from his attorney when I answered
the phone he simply said are you sitting
down and I said yes and he said are you
ready to cry like a baby and I said yes
how hopeful are you that your son will
finally come home it's the first time
that I've actually had any hope the
criminal complaint says Nico was taken
by his mother
Marcel Iggy Morris in July of 2013
nearly a year after the couple divorced
she claimed they were going to Brazil
for a wedding and never returned
according to the FBI Marcela's parents
67 year old Carlos Kumar ice and a 62
year old wife gymnema helped carry out
the plot a criminal complaint secretly
filed by federal prosecutors last year
alleges Nico's grandmother helped enroll
him in a Brazilian school two months
before his trip it also says Nico's
grandfather Carlos bought plane tickets
to make it seem like Nico was coming
back to Texas do you believe
Miko's grandparents deserve to be jail I
that justice should be served I don't
know that I'm in favor of them
you know being in jail into perpetuity
with her parents in custody bran hopes
his ex-wife will want to start serious
discussions about returning Niko a Texas
judge granted him the right to decide
where Niko should live but the Brazilian
courts have so far ignored it brand only
gets to see his son in Brazil every two
to three months
he's worried Marcel II will use the
grandparents arrests to turn his son
against him my hope sure and simple is
that
Niko comes home that we can make amends
that we can move on with our lives and
that Nico will have equal access to both
parents in his life because that's what
he deserves
the grandparents will make their first
appearance in federal court next week
they each could face up to eight years
in prison if convicted now in a
statement to CBS Marcela Gilmer Isis
attorney said her clients parents are
not related to this case and mr. bran
has regular access to see his son John
Michell thanks